okay you know what you know what's
actually unbelievable i wanna i wanna
talk about this is
um i i was i was so i was at the laugh
factory last night
and um
i uh was having a good time and the
doctor told me not to
do any shows yet because i might
activate my nose and start nose bleeding
and that would be bad for the recovery
and i told him i was like well okay
and he said just um like if you're doing
your podcast and and your nose might
start bleeding and i was like oh [ __ ] i
already did like three podcasts i didn't
know he didn't mean i didn't know he
meant don't do podcasts i didn't manage
to go on stage so i'm like i could
probably go on stage
[Music]
so it's at the lab factory and and uh
they were like do you want to go up and
i was like the doctor said i shouldn't
but you know what i kind of feel good
um
and then my friend was like just do 10
minutes at the end and i was like yeah
i'm a [ __ ] headliner
i can't shred this [ __ ] place right
be a pop in i'll sure would like the
insecurity in me sure would like to hear
up
an unexpected roar from the audience
that i wasn't
gonna be here
i am insecure hmm
i think okay i'll do 10 minutes
he did say hmm the guy did say it was a
tight crowd and i sure would like to
shove it up his [ __ ] ass when he can
show him that you could [ __ ]
absolutely shred this place hmm
i am insecure yeah i'll do 10 minutes if
my no bleeds nosebleeds whatever so i
say to the manager i was like yeah i'll
go up and she's like are you sure it's
okay i know the doctor said and i was
like we'll find out it'll be fine
i went up did you know it was good could
show this is not what the story is about
the story is about
afterwards i get off stage and just i
want to let me just blank it before this
story starts let me just blanketly say
this
dude i
i don't know when it turned but like
[ __ ] man
comedians
are so
[ __ ] annoying
like
i'm and i and like dude some of my
closest friends and favorite people are
comedians so i don't mean all of them
but i mean as a whole like 95 of them
are just
garbage and i don't mean on stage yes on
stage but just like
garbage at hanging around
like just [ __ ] they're like an old
[ __ ] crinkled up tuna can and some
[ __ ] and a milk carton that's got
like half in it and some cigarette butts
they're [ __ ]
garbage dude at hanging out
and they just come up to you and they do
bits
and you're like oh
oh
this is maybe a comedian from new york
that i don't know and then they walk
away and you find out that they've been
doing comedy for like eight months and
they're just uh they just somehow snuck
in upstairs at the laugh factory and
started roasting your shoes
and you're like oh you're just
garbage
oh by me oh my mistake you're some
[ __ ] crinkled up toilet paper that
didn't get used for wiping someone's ass
you're in the garbage
it's just like
because here's the thing too like a lot
of successful comedians are garbage at
hanging out but
but dude
that's fine because you know what you
kind of have to be annoying to be a good
comedian so let like you have to be good
to be a good comedian because you have
to always be crack practicing your craft
and sometimes that means you've got to
be trying to be funny when it's not
called for and that's the essence of
being annoying so if you're garbage at
hanging out that's okay but you can work
on your talent and craft it there i say
to where you actually can kill on stage
but if you don't have that talent
then you're garbage at both
dude then just get another profession
this whole live your dreams thing
give up after five years
you're just annoying the [ __ ] at
everyone and asking people to come to
shows
dude i got off stage and this dude
started hanging around around the back
bar that's only for waitresses and
comedians he was just standing around
and he was like can i get a beer and
they were like sure yeah
are you on the show and he was like no
not this one no and we're like oh cool
are we on the next one and he was just
like
and they're like oh okay
he was like cool excuse me and then he
stood right next to me and there was
like such open space everywhere else and
i was like what's up dude and he just
goes
and i and and finally my buddy was like
bro you're weird huh
and he was like what
he was like what's up dude do you do
stand up and he was like yeah i'd do
some mics here and there and i'm like
all right well okay hey guy
pack it up
you wanna take it
dude you're
some oatmeal no one ate
like you're you're
[ __ ]
garbage
it's so
maddening and then you got guys with
like netflix specials hanging around
like bill burr and then some [ __ ]
rolled up banana peel will walk by
and be like hey you mind if i sit with
you no
go in a glad bag
get cinched [ __ ]
it's it's so and then afterwards some
chick came up to me was like why'd you
unfollow me
and i'm like
and i you know she goes on stage
sometimes why'd you unfollow me and the
whole and here's dude she took my phone
when i met her and she was like you
don't even follow me all your friends
follow me let me see grab my phone
followed herself and then i unfollowed
her afterwards and then she approached
me and she said you unfollowed me
i never
followed you
you're some oatmeal no one is
dude how can people be
such
[ __ ]
cold oatmeal
how can you be
get a clue like dude and here's the
other thing too here's what happens man
is because stand up
has the
lowest
entry-level
job
that that you
can have
out of anything and like
all you have to do
is decide
that's it
all you got to do is decide and go to a
comedy club that's that's it then all of
a sudden you're at the lowest and you're
at the you're at your entry level right
you go walk up to the comedy store and
be like
i'm a comedian can i hang out
okay cool
and then you're there and you're like
standing next to [ __ ] sebastian
maniscalco and they're they're like
we're and you're like where'd you get
that jacket it's kind of cool and it's
like this guy sells out stadiums
the nerve dude
it's so [ __ ] annoying it's the most
annoying [ __ ] dude and none of these
clubs in la have like security so it's
always like you're always like standing
in the green room and then you're like
what who's this person standing next to
me and they're like yeah my
my [ __ ] they're this
and you're just all right dude who is
this
hey
who are you
you're in the 95 percent of people that
are that can't even hang out right
you can't even
be
your cold oatmeal
congratulations
it's so annoying dude
sign up for our patreon
patreon.comcrystalia
and i set it there in case that's the
clip we use to promote it crazy
crazy
crazy
[Music]